okay let's get to audience questions
first one hey David could you lay out a
basic financial plan for someone who
works and is middle-class but just has
no idea what to do
I understand lots of people aren't in a
position to save any money but it would
be great to hear you talk about what
middle-class people should be doing yeah
I I've hesitated to do this number one
because I don't want to be condescending
to anybody based on their financial
situation and also because I don't want
to be giving financial advice so let me
say none of this this is all
hypothetical it's not advice for
anyone's specific situation but some
basic principles are if you don't have a
thousand dollars in an emergency fund
you need a thousand dollars in an
emergency fund and not having it I would
consider an emergency you need to
significantly curtail all spending until
you have that thousand dollars that we
did a story not long ago about how some
very high percentage of Americans would
not be able to afford an unexpected four
hundred dollar expense without like
putting it on a credit card or borrowing
from friends that's a real problem so
you need a thousand dollars because of
the health care system we have you
probably in addition to the thousand
should also have whatever your
deductible is if your deductible yearly
is two thousand dollars on health
insurance you probably want that in
addition to the thousand-dollar
emergency fund that's just a reality and
then you want to be working towards a
three to six month not now it's no
longer an emergency fund but sort of an
income replacement fund the ideal
scenario would be to have six months of
if you if your income went to zero you
could pay for everything you're
currently paying for for six months that
would be a great place to be and whether
that's practical for different people
really depends on their situation you
want to avoid high interest credit card
debt it you ideally would just be paying
I use my credit card like a debit card I
use it for frequent flier miles and I
pay it off every month not everybody can
do that I understand that but you want
to be avoiding any fees and interest
that are not necessary because it just
takes away it's money you're just giving
away to financial institutions and then
you do want to think a little bit about
your sort of general asset allocation
and this
includes thinking about retirement plans
what how much cash should you have
versus money in tax deferred investment
accounts versus in real estate for
example so again everybody's situation
is very different
just having cash you know having a whole
bunch of cash and then not really
contributing to anything that is going
to grow in terms of a retirement account
or an investment account is not
particularly wise I'm being deliberately
vague again because I am NOT giving
specific financial advice but as an
example I used to invest in mutual funds
in real estate investment trusts are
EITS
REITs as they're called and it's like a
proxy for investing in real estate when
I actually started getting involved in
in real estate directly with properties
that I'm involved with I realized it's
too much real estate I should stop
investing in the REITs and maybe look at
reallocating that to something else my
philosophy on investing is don't pick
stocks look for the lowest cost broadest
mutual funds and figure out what is your
balance between stocks and bonds there
are lots of tools out there one says you
take the number 120 and subtract the
number 100 and subtract your age and
that's the percent you want to be in
stock so if you're in if you're 30 years
old you want to be 70% in stocks which
actually seems a little bit conservative
maybe for my tastes but there's all
these tools that will help you figure
that out when it comes to things like
mortgages very often it is not logical
to take a huge chunk of money and pay
off the mortgage if you actually figure
out the numbers financially because
there is a tax benefit to paying
mortgage interest and if your mortgage
is 4% and you can invest in something
that historically returns 7% you're
better off taking the money and putting
it into the investment instead of into
the mortgage but everybody's situation
is different there's a sort of
psychological value to paying down or
paying off a mortgage which what might
make it the right thing for some
people even if they are effectively
accepting a lower return as a result so
these it's really hard to have a sort of
overarching financial plan but my my
sort of tips in general are you need a
thousand dollars right away plus your
health insurance exposed exposure the
amount you're exposed to health
insurance spending in an emergency fund
working towards six months of expenses
in case you earn nothing for six months
you want to ensure that you are not on
the hedonic treadmill and that your
expenses are properly attuned to your
income and you don't want to start
spending more every time you make a
little more don't get into the cycle of
living beyond your means in terms of
using high interest credit card debt for
anything other than absolute necessities
again if you use it like a debit card to
accrue points and you pay it off and
fold that's okay
and then you want to be contributing as
much as you can in the most advantaged
way possible towards retirement so if
your employer offers a 50% match up to
six percent of your income you if you
can afford it want to be contributing 6
percent of your income to that
retirement plan to get the 3 percent
from your employer because that's quote
free money of course nothing is really
free you can make the case that your
salary is lower because your employer is
already accounting for that in the offer
to match your contributions 50 cents on
the dollar up to 6 percent but still
it's money that's available and you want
to be taking advantage of that and and
really a lot of this stuff comes to do
comes back to the tax impact so it is
important to read up on or have an
accountant that can advise you for
example about with the recent from tax
reform now that there has been a limit
placed on the deductibility of certain
types of taxes is it as advantageous to
have that mortgage or would it be better
to look at paying it down and investing
the money elsewhere etc this is all very
vague stuff but I hope I'm at least
telling you sort of like a basic
framework that I apply and again when it
comes to any kind of investment one of
your top priorities should be
reduce the cost Vanguard and betterment
without giving any particular
endorsements
have fees that are so low sometimes
point oh three point oh five percent
compared to what sometimes our one or
two percent management fees for similar
asset allocation in other institutions
so pay very very close attention to that
okay that does it for that question
let's move on and I'm glad to take more
questions about this someone actually
had the idea David you should do on your
twitch stream when it whenever you
launch it you should just do like
personal finance stuff since your
background is in personal finance from
grad school it's an interesting idea I
think I'm just kind of out of the game
and I wouldn't really be the right
person to be giving that kind of advice
which could be funny in a sense but I
also don't want to damage anybody's
financial circumstances